I took a Doctoral degree in what was then called,
Computer Science, in between med school and residency.
It was a hobby because no one could imagine why a doctor would want a computer.
So as I practiced in the academic environment for the next 25 or 30 years,
most of the interest came peripherally about the application of computers to health care.
I began my career in Medical Informatics full time about 20 years ago.
In today's world, we are burdened with
far too much information to make adequate decisions in a timely manner,
be accurate, up to date and appropriate for the patient.
We come to the decision process ill prepared to take care of our patients.
The technology now is able to provide us the kinds of support we need to reduce errors,
improve the care of patients and diminish skyrocketing cost.
HL7 began 31 years ago in a classroom
at the University of Pennsylvania with one goal in mind,
improving access to admission data.
Quickly, it evolved into clinical information and began a journey to try to enable
the sharing of data in a large ubiquitous environment that could
be seamless and yet deeply integrated with the way we care for patients.
Quickly, it was recognized that this is not simply a US centric process and
members of HL7 identify themselves all over the world.
And now we have members in 35 countries in every continent representing the,
sometimes local needs but often the global needs for care, public health,
research and the very core kinds of competencies that are fundamental for better health.
Six years ago, we began a program called Fresh Look.
What if we could start all over,
reinvent HL7 but careful to acknowledge
all the things we had learned about what we did right and what we had done not so right?
At that program, Graham Griff presented his vision for health care and operability,
which quickly was transformed into what we now envision in FHIR.
And although the adoption process was not immediate,
universally it was recognized that this shared many of the common elements that have made
commerce information exchange and the sharing of data
in public communication so simple and straightforward.
That technology was leveraged and made part of the fundamental elements of FHIR.
I think perhaps more importantly,
was a different focus for FHIR.
Unlike some of the earlier HL7 standards,
FHIR was really made an important part of the implementation community.
We didn't focus simply on the individuals
and stakeholder groups that needed to use our standards,
but on the people who would be the providers and end users of a product,
for whom, this has been the greatest leap of value.
I think the visionaries who developed FHIR,
realized this from the very start.
I think acknowledgement by a larger community,
like any other new idea,
required time and a great deal of effort.
Part of that was made simple by two fundamental processes.
One, we didn't charge for FHIR.
And secondly, we allowed a broad international community to contribute not only
to the development of the FHIR standard but the implementation of FHIR as a tool.
It transcended any other activity in its ease of use,
its global recognition and its adoption by a diverse community.
Not only is it about caregivers but also the research community,
the organizations that rely on population health.
And in the United States,
where we have multi payer systems,
the payer communities who now need clinical data more than ever,
are embracing the ease and ubiquity of a FHIR platform.
Some segments, some stakeholder groups and some individuals,
were far slower than others.
I can tell you that I was pleasantly
surprised by the diverse stakeholder groups,
who found FHIR to be useful.
I think in the communities that are not easily changed,
there is always a hurdle.
Change management is one of the great obstacles,
whether in the private sector or the public one.
And I think the access that HL7 provided to FHIR,
the ease of acceptance,
really accelerated the process in ways that I never anticipated.
I wrote in the HR in 1981.
It served one business case,
physicians in an academic medical center couldn't find the chart.
The paper charts were distributed in a host of different places.
The electronic medical record,
if you want to call what I produced,
simply allowed continuity so you could find out what happened the last week.
FHIR presents a host of opportunities because for me,
an electronic medical record,
is a lot more than simply a tool to document care.
It's an open resource for
the kind of clinical decision support that is so paramount as we transition,
from physicians who could imagine all the things they needed
to know in a few concepts.
We're now exploding with information,
not just about the clinical condition,
the therapies, the guidelines,
but also in the broad field of genomics and proteomics,
which will bring us concepts that are really beyond what humans can consume.
So the decision process has eased.
The sharing of information for
a continuous learning system is enabled because the delays in bringing
new ideas and new concepts to
health care from the research community are far too slow and far too expensive.
And so, FHIR presents a unique bridge to go
from one stakeholder group to another and the information moves rather seamlessly.
In the ensuing decade,
I expect the number of pieces of data that any clinician needs to make a decision,
will be beyond human reasoning.
FHIR will enable the kind of integration of diverse data.
We will have platforms that we had not imagined.
In fact, we have a program which is unique in my experience,
in which stakeholders who have produced FHIR apps, showcase this.
Our FHIR app round table,
is one of the most enjoyable moments in my year,
in which I get to see the kinds of
ideas that are brought to the fore that I had never imagined you could do with data.
And more importantly, the developers of these products have an opportunity to
collaborate and bring yet unique ideas to the fore with an ease,
that I don't think even they imagined.
And I suspect that in the coming decade,
HL7 will be transformed into a facilitator of that process.